Oh, (617) 830-4750 let's jump over to our
caller from the seven oh eight area code.
Who's calling today from seven Oh eight, seven
oh eight maybe we're muted.
I don't know.
Yo.
Oh, sorry.
Hi.
How are you,
Mason?
Yeah, my name is [inaudible].
I'm from Chicago.
What's going on?
I wanted to ask, um, so you, you've seen the
Joe Rogan podcast with Bernie Sanders.
Uh, I saw five minutes of it.
Honestly, I don't know what else happened.
I saw that, you know, it had thousands of
downvotes, not surprisingly, based on Joe's
audience.
Um, and I saw that he was on, I saw the first
five minutes.
Why did, did anything interesting go on?
Oh No, no.
The, they just, they just discussed a lot
of, um, I mean, it was, it was really well,
uh, it was really well, uh, discussed.
Uh, you guys should probably watch it.
Um, yeah, I was gonna I was gonna ask.
Um, do you think other candidates just show
up on the Joe Rogan experience?
It's up to them.
I mean, I think so.
Andrew Yang did it.
Tulsi Gabber did it.
I don't know who else has been on with him,
but he, I mean, it's a huge platform.
It's one of the biggest podcasts around, I
don't think, I mean I don't believe any publicity
is good publicity, but certainly the Joe Rogan
experience is good publicity no matter what
your political orientation is.
I feel like I'm just, just from a, I mean
listen, even if his audience is like a center,
right audience in total, like a lot of people
didn't like the stuff I said on there, but
it still was hugely beneficial for me.
So like, yeah, I think why, why wouldn't I?
I can't think of any reason why candidates
would avoid it.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Can you, I mean, what is there, do you think
candidates should stay away from the show?
No, no, no.
I think I'm, I think he has interesting, I
think he asks great questions and since we're
on the podcasts they can talk as long as they
want versus a debate, which is like 15 seconds
of response time, so, right.
I think it's very nice.
Okay.
You're in your question, you sounded a little
bit like hesitant, like do what you know that
maybe people think they shouldn't be on or
something.
No, I only sent it hesitant because you, you
didn't watch the entire, uh, Bernie though
the entire Bernie podcast, so that's why I
was like, that's why I was hesitant on the
question.
Oh, okay.
Got It.
Nevermind on that.
No, I mean, as a general, I don't have to
watch that specific episode to say huge platform,
long form, which is great compared to the
debates as you're pointing out.
So yeah, why I think candidates should do
it.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
Appreciate all day from Chicago, right to
hear from you.